get back get back get
back me an Arkansas cop is beat up by a
group of teenage girls and the entire
thing is caught on body Hammer video Che
you
out
blood what started as Halloween trick or
treating soon turned sour when the team
were arrested for the
[Music]
attack got her
yeah I don't care I don't care it
happened on Halloween in Hot Springs
Arkansas about an hour Southwest of
Little Rock it was about 7:15 that
evening when Lieutenant Kenny May saw
the group group of girls walking along
the street when he noticed a girl throw
a can into the road he pulled his squad
over and confronted the
kids I
can I
again what is you talking about listen
to me the next time I see you throw
trash you going to go to jail you're
going to go to jail as video shows May
warns the girls they will be arrested if
it happens again but almost right away
they begin talking back and closing in
on him
hey you hey you get out of my face thank
you I need a couple in the block when
the group starts to walk away May
follows telling the girls they're not
above the law just because they're
minors don't give a your a minor
hey hey hey tell her to come down to the
police department and see me my name's
Lieutenant May hey hey I don't care if
you're mad tell her to come see me my
name is Lieutenant May it's then that
one of the girls again throws the can
but this time it's directly at may I
don't care if you're mad tell her to
come see me my name's Lieutenant may may
continues walking with the girls later
telling fellow officers he planned to
follow them home and tell their parents
about the littering but as this
continues the girls refuse to call their
parents and yell profanities toward
May yeah
glad not touch me I'm calling my mother
move come here no if you touch me I
swear to I'm not do I look like I'm
touching you yes you just push me I
would talking to
you hey call your mom so I can find out
where you live call your mom so I can
find out where you live call your mom
call your mom so I can find he I don't
care I don't care I a can your and then
threw it at hey and then threw it at me
so that's a that's a different story hey
call your mom like what are you doing
call your
mom I'm not going to touch you
call okay call your
mom call your
mom I'm super extra hey call your call
your mom you can call your mom too when
may calls for backup the argument
intensifies if you I the parents run
away nobody on the way because I don't
no I need to talk to him I want to talk
to him for throwing this at at a cop
I didn't even
touch throwing it at a
top it's all on it's all on camera y'all
are making y'all are making hey get out
of my face get out of my face the
yelling continues before one of the
girls grabs may he continues to yell for
them to back off but they refuse and one
even throws something at
him
you're gonna
get because you can't because you're my
investigation that's
why get back get
back me Fu
back
[Music]
get
back you're doing to the next moments
happen quickly as May takes one of the
girls to the ground according to a
release from the Hot Springs Police
Department that's when the other three
girls begin hitting him in the face and
neck at the same time backup officers
arrive on the scene and help to break up
the
fight hey you better put your head
behind your
[Music]
[Applause]
back body camera video shows the Mayhem
as the four girls are put into
[Music]
handcuffs calm down slow
down yeah I'm good I'm good you're good
it's your teenage girls trying not
[Music]
to as the video shows the girls continue
screaming and yelling even as they're
taken into a squad
[Music]
car we're getting a a crowd if we have
one or two more that can come this way I
didn't
do let's start
a get off my
let's start getting them in
car and we'll take him to the police
department get up get
[Music]
up hop
in when one of the girls who allegedly
punched May says she's complying now he
says it's too little too late the one
that punched me is getting put in next
see take them all to the PD we'll call
parents from there so we don't get a
crowd off the you got cups
on get
up okay I'm comping to you now you
punched me in the face you're not
compliant you punched me first no I
didn't I pushed you back did it's all on
camera you're good oh my God can y'all
call my mama please yeah please I've
been trying to get you to call your mom
my okay too late I'm okay with that too
late to be
nicee your mom face
first I don't have anything
well you're under arrest okay a battery
on an
officer you can't
me do you want me to lift up my shirt
like nope we don't need you to do
anything else except do what we tell to
do going water my no we're
not can I get my no ma'am get your foot
in so it doesn't get shut in the door
okay
okay during this time one of the girls
suffers an asthma attack when may says
he'll call for EMS so that she can be
checked out another officer points out
May could also need medical care start
calling parents now we're looking for
as well hey before we transfer her let's
I tell you
what no Hey where's your Asma pump let's
let's get her in a different unit have
life
Life Net emergent for a asthma attack on
a
juvenile hey we're going to have life
nck come check you out
okay
out blood oh do
I later May explains to fellow officers
what led up to this physical altercation
I was driving by they just chumped a Red
Bull can so I was just going to stop
like pick it up when they pick it up
start running I'm like don't run away
from me so they start off running I'm
just going to fall into their house and
uh one of them tried to get in the way
of me so I pushed her out of the way and
then all three of them I mean were
actively like I mean I'm backing up like
they're juvenile girls you're not want
to just box them I'm backing up like
this and finally when I heard sirens
they kept coming I said get back I push
them one time they didn't get back and
then I start then I took one down and
then everybody else jumped out and took
the other two go
jail yeah two girls on you yeah so on
dash c yeah so how many we got custy I
got one i' got one three or four okay
got three and they're good she's good
she came up after looking for your as
next May checks on one of the girls
who's been sitting in the back of a
squad car for several minutes when he
opens the door may quickly realizes she
wasn't spending that time cooling
off oh that's
it anything
else okay in the end May explains again
that what started as a littering call
ended in a physical fight with a group
of girls it's a littering call so yeah
there'll be a littering report just
upload those into that dude so so this
whole thing this is crazy well man I
came around the corner and I had the one
that was on your back and I just tackled
her on the ground dude
like I just sign for a Red Bull can and
I was going to stop hey man pick up the
can well they pick it up and start
running I'm like hey don't run changed
like just come back and talk to him for
a minute and it's automatically F you
and I and all this and uh say like I'm
running home I'm like cool I'm just
going to follow you home and I'm going
to talk to Mom and Dad
and one of them like tried to cut me off
on the other one and I'm like one of
them tried to cut me off from the other
one so I just kind of shoved her out of
the way dude then all three of them
you're trying not to just like punch the
teenage girl right because the girls are
all minors their faces were blurred in
this video and their names have not been
released but we do know they each now
face charges of battery in the second
degree reporting for La crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie